(dramatic orchestral music)
(drone propellers thumping)
[Drone] Citizens, remain calm.
Alpha Team, assemble. C formation.
[Drone] Copy, Orange Leader.
Standing by to targets.
(drones buzzing)
(birds singing)
(dramatic orchestral music)
[Drone] Ladies and
gentlemen, do not be alarmed.
This is a socially-distant
delivery from Conan O'Brien.
Stand back. Delivery incoming.
Oh man.
[Drone] Where's the drop button?
Whoops.
Oh my god.
[Drone] Delivery successful.
I'm kinda scared.
Oh my god!
Oh my god! It's Funko Pops!
[Audience] Wow!
Conan as Wonder Woman.
Chucky.
It's Aquaman.
Marty McFly.
Dr. Ian Malcolm.
We're gonna need a bigger boat.
[Drone] Sir, you've got
the wrong Spielberg movie.
So many Conans.
[Drone] Goodbye, humans.
Conan!
[Drone] Enjoy your viral collectibles.